[Musik]
leoni habe bei der arbeit die 33-jährige
deutsche influenza rinn ist bei der
fashionshow von dior in paris dort sitzt
sie in der ersten reihe
selbstverständlich im neuesten look der
marke das französische luxuslabel ist
ein sogenannter partner mit denen die
influenza den seit einigen jahren
zusammen arbeitet
ich wollte eigentlich in silber look
anziehen und dann hat einer der
allergrößten diäten ähnlichen locken hat
mich heute morgen die augen von tcn den
lock und zum glück hatte ich noch was in
der reserve deswegen wurde es jetzt
ungeplant wurden
während der schauen wie hier bei der
pariser modewoche jagt ein termin den
nächsten
festgehalten wird alles auf ihrem
instagram account mit fast 4 millionen
followern gehört leonie hanne zu den
erfolgreichsten mode influenza europas
gottseidank interessieren sich meine
follower tatsächlich für das was wir tun
ich bin zum beispiel jetzt in paris
besser gewachsen als im letzten jahr
obwohl wir so viel gepostet haben oder
könnte auch den leuten zu viel aber es
bringt richtig spaß weil ich sehe wie
die community mitglied und dann fühlt
man sich auch einen anstrengenden tag
immer so voller motivation war weiß da
sitzen leute und wir gucken zu und sagen
zunächst das outfit minister lockt das
bringt spaß als richtig schön
influence so wie sie sind die stars von
heute leonie hanna hat ihren eigenen
shop höher wenn sie unterwegs ist wohnt
sie im 5 sterne hotel und wird von den
marken hofiert doch was nach einem luxus
leben aussieht ist auch harte arbeit
es ist auf jeden fall gegen zeit von
glamourös umso größer ist aussieht umso
weniger glamourös war es meistens das
werk war in venedig und cannes bei den
filmfestspielen und umso schickes
aussehen leute hängen sowohl er in the
best life ist es in echt fünf stunden
arbeit drei minuten red carpet viel
laufen viel rennen die leute denkt der
ganze tag war nur in roben aber ein
echtes ist immer anders als man denkt
aber es gehört auch dazu dass dann wie
so zu verpacken dass es nur noch klemm
aussieht wenn leonie hanna auf den
modeschauen unterwegs ist muss sie sich
meistens im auto umziehen mehrmals am
tag wechselt sie das outfit
wir fragen aber kurz ein fahrerpaar
ausgeht dann haben ein freundlich platz
ich ziemlich um bevor ich das auto
verlassen guckt er eigentlich wenn also
was nicht passt es ist seine schuld
ohne fahrer schafft man tatsächlich
nicht mehrere shows in der reihe weil
man sich gar nicht umziehen kann
so schon dafür braucht man im kofferraum
immer an ihrer seite lebens und
geschäftspartner alexander gajewski
kennengelernt haben sich die beiden beim
wirtschaftsstudium in hamburg
sie arbeiten jetzt seit sechs jahren
zusammen
[Musik]
das was viele jetzt beim blocken
unterschätzen ist natürlich das ganz
viel geschäftssinn ist also wir fahren
ja selber unseren sketche was wir machen
wollen planen projekte überlegen wie wir
uns in die vom image positionieren
wollen ähnliches da wird ganz viel witz
gips wirtschaft dazu für mode hat sich
die gebürtige hamburgerin eigentlich
schon immer interessiert
bei uns die artothek aufgemacht habe ich
in der 40 angefangen zu arbeiten
ich war auch mal bei modelagenturen aber
ich bin sehr sehr stark im kopf mensch
analytischer mensch mehr das damals
nicht gefallen das war mir quasi gesagt
hat dass meine meinung nicht so wichtig
ist und dass ich eigentlich nur
abliefern soll was man mir sagt das ist
heute anders leonie hanne ist so etwas
wie model und geschäftsfrau in einem
arbeit vergnügen und privatleben gehen
fließend ineinander über und ihre
follower sind stets dabei
[Musik]